il y a quelques grands enjeux qui ont
été d'ailleurs soulevés en partie par l'
Act le nouveau le règlement européen qui
a été annoncé par Thierry Breton
vendredi dernier c'est finalement quel
fonctionnement de la sphère publique
dans une perspective de l'intelligence
artificielle alors le premier enjeu à
mon sens c'est ce qu'on appelle euh les
les services paramétriques ou le Crédit
Social suivant là où on se place crédit
social c'est ce modèle chinois vous en
avez entendu parler vous traversez le
feu rouge moi je l'ai vu de mes yeux
j'ai vraiment vu de mes yeux je baladant
avec un copain chinois à chenzen vous
êtes passé au rouge vous arrivez de
l'autre côté du feu vous avez
l'équivalent d' 1 € d'amende vous êtes
pas encore de l'autre côté vous avez
déjà reçu l'alerte qui vous dit que vous
avez un dollar d'amende donc ce truc
existe mais si vous voulez est dans les
il y dit explicitement qu'on a pas le
droit de faire ça en réalité c'est déjà
partout c'est que quand vous roulez sur
l'autoroute que vous êtes à 90 km/h au
lieu de 80 enfin pas sur l'autoroute
mais voilà c'est c'est un système qui
est paramétrique qui est automatisé et
en France ça n'est pas encore le cas
mais dans les pays scandinaves l'accès
au droit est automatisé c'est que vous
recevez de l'argent l'équivalent du RSA
sur votre relevé de compte vous n'avez
rien demandé on a rapproché vos données
sociales de vos données fiscales et et
on vous le donne de façon
automatique je je il y a tout un tas de
de parcours sup c'est un système
paramétrique la l'algorithme de la CAF
dont on parle beaucoup ces jour-ci c'est
un système paramétrique ces systèmes
sont amenés qu' le veuille ou non à
envahir la sphère publique pour des
questions de productivité des services
publics et la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est pas de savoir si on doit les
interdire ou pas c'est comment on peut
garantir l'équité des citoyens face à ce
genre de choses
et rien que ce sujet pourrait nous
occuper pendant une partie de
l'après-midi mais mon
sentiment pour avoir quand même beaucoup
travailler là-dessus notamment à la
Commission européenne où j'étais en
charge d'une partie de ces sujets j'ai
visité quasiment 24 des des 28 à
l'époque pays membres pour échanger sur
ces sujets c'est que à moyen terme il
nous faudra une évolution force forte
des institutions publiques pour faire en
sorte que les citoyens ne fassent plus
face à l'état mais soit au cœur de
l'État et au cœur de la construction de
l'État et que finalement les garants
Infiné du fait que il y aura un maintien
de l'équité face à ces modèles et bien
ce
seront les citoyens qui auront accès à
la transparence des algorithmes et qui
veilleront à ce que ces algorithmes ne
soit pas euh discriminant